oh my goodness
and Knight D7 Rook takes B8 and Rook d8
oh my God where you can't do that
in 2020 nvl defeated Magnus Carlson in
the speed Chess Championship semi-finals
the only defeat in Carlson's speed Chess
Championship career after his match
against Carolina Carlson looked ahead to
playing mvl and said he was eager to
exact a part of his revenge today
Carlson got to work in game one claiming
a clean night in-game win but in game
two mvl applied big pressure with a
queen against a rook and minor piece oh
gosh where's that King going Bishop A7
check a huge threat oh my gosh it is a
huge threaten King H3 gets checkmated
Bishop A7 anyway rookie 3. yeah it is a
draw King F3 and King G2 back rookie
three rookie two don't go crazy if your
Maxine take the draw and same goes for
Magnus what a game in game three in the
L went to work trying to convert an
extra Pawn three seconds Rook Aces he
wants Rook a two perhaps he has in his
back pocket if you want to trade Rooks
does Rook A5 with the paper oh National
C3 and E4 was the thread he's gonna lose
oh my gosh in his last SEC match Carlson
achieved a historic win against Fabiano
caruana going undefeated already in game
three in the semi-finals mvl had a
victory showing that Carlson would have
a tougher task ahead of him today
Carlson showed his famous Flawless
in-game technique in game four pressing
in an opposite colored Bishop in game
with equal pawns major practical chances
for black would you agree oh absolutely
King got five King G4 already looks
scary and now King effect also H4
that is basic Betty right there now H3
and the pawn is Unstoppable yeah King H4
the pawn remains defended don't go H2
because I'm broke h8 checked it's the
one thing six maybe he's also playing
for mate he's gonna deliver it that is a
Magnus Master Class NBL stole a pawn in
game five but Magnus applied counter
pressure could nvl convert okay I buy
the activity but I also love an extra
pawn and it's a healthy opponent that
it is and MBO could support that extra
Pawn with Rook B8 to d8 he needs to
properly apportion the work for his
Rooks he goes Rook C4 yeah and if you
take D takes D4 he goes Rook D6 now
there's no Knight C3 rugby
oh my goodness
and Knight t7 Rook takes B8 and Rook d8
oh my God no way you can't do that he
simply blundered a full night here King
G2 the one thing you don't want for
white is to treat all of the Pawns
no he just he's done he's like I'm I'm
done with this gun a 98 accuracy game
was smoothly drawn in the sixth battle
but Carlson won again convincingly in
game seven and eight before a draw in
the ninth closed out the five plus one
time control with Carlson leading six
and a half to two and a half
India was fighting toe-to-toe with
Carlson but he had to capitalize on more
of his chances
mvl played like the Leon Beastie is in
the beginning of the three plus one time
control pressing hard in an ultimately
drawn game before pressuring an error
out of Carlson in game two what is
happening Bishop before maybe was a more
prudent way to stop Knight D6 yeah or
Bishop G5 was available what whoa when
he blundered a piece he blundered
him Magnus Carlton is human
blundered a piece Maxine caused problems
the f file and the diagonal and look at
Magnus sitting back in his chair he does
not look happy and Maxime is simply up a
piece you better win this game
you have to win this you are morally
obligated uh to exploit the gifts that
the world champion gives you because he
is not going to give you that many of
them he might give you one the entire
match could mvl convert the extra piece
smoothly and white is just attacking and
not only is the bishop not helpful
Robert it's also harmful it's creating
problems with the back rank Magnus picks
up another pawn and he's gonna restrain
wax passer with 94. he might not even be
that much worse here he might even win
this game in his pawns again oh no no no
no no no don't shoot don't you speak
that language I'm just looking you're
absolutely right it goes for a trade
and each Pawn the H Pawn is the wrong
Pawn Dania so let's keep that in mind if
a rook trade you need to trade the g65
before you make a draw what a call by
Magnus he sees that he's gonna go G4 yes
wait he should have done it on the
previous move but it still might be a
draw yeah I guess you can't make
progress the king just shuffles in F2
and G2 and the bishop
King D5 G4 he's gonna make it G4 now and
since you're unreal unbelievable save I
mean what does this guy what can't this
guy do but this is why I bring it up
time and time again bishop and the H1
Square do not match that means it's a
draw even though you're up a healthy
Four Points of material wow what a hold
from Magnus Crosby blunders a full piece
down here how do you beat this guy not
perturbed by this painful Miss mvl built
up a winning position in The Rook end
game in the third three plus one game
he's not finding the way
yes Rook F6 and then A7 Rook up step six
first no and he can play
he had the Intermezzo and he missed it
and now it's a draw the king is
shouldered this is an easy draw from
Magnus Carlson and Maxima Sherlock
should be beside himself because he just
needs a blockade the pawn we'll show you
this after the game concludes but that
is such a missed opportunity and we keep
saying it he needs to put Magnus away
and he is in disbelief disgusted
with the biggest Miss of the match can
you believe he choked that after two
such brutal missed wins it was mvl's
turn to be on the worst side of things
in the next two games but these were
also drawn
with opposite colored Bishops in a
sterile endgame the sixth three plus one
game also appeared to be heading for a
draw he's not going to be down upon he
grabs it but MPL needs to play
cautiously for a couple moves here to
secure the drop and I think he's doing
just that yeah he defends the pawn on B5
preemptively does Rook F5 which is even
one to follow oh I don't I don't like H5
I thought mdl should have put his rope
on C5 what's he doing
Rook C1 Rook C2 and Bishop E1 maybe but
that was just very artificial Rook C1
Rook C2 there's Bishop A4 the bishop on
B4 is loose there no what is Maxime
doing
oh my gosh goodbye one Bang Bang
yeah Bishop F7 rookie six is a mate
threat
oh that is a heartbreaker ndl was
determined to attack and now he went for
a scary looking sack with Knight to E6
96. oh wait I don't believe in this
because black could even first of all
I'd like to play Queen B6 and I feel
like that Knight is a paper Tiger yep
second of all black and play Queen V6
and third of all Magnus play Queen B6
yep know that first second third does
check out Knight takes D5 is now kind of
a threat
what's the guy doing on E6 or just F
takes E6 right you've there's no more
night hanging on D7
yeah take the Knight and go Queen E7
even better
just give me a heartless and he wins
another game he is up by six points
Donya and that was a dominant display
right out of the gates a draw in the
penultimate game preceded an excellent
demonstration of strong play in the
Italian game from MBL to finish off the
three plus one time control and now
black is collapsing I think that's it
because Rook B6 remember Rook C2
something like King D6 now moving
that's fast so Magnus Carlson loses on
the board on time but he still has a
five point lead at this moment Maxine
Russia leaves his chair Donya that was
impressive by Maxine in this game India
had improved a lot in the three plus one
time control but Carlson still won the
segment five to four and he had
stretched his lead to five games
after a pair of opening draws mvl found
a brilliant move that even elicited a
smile from Carlson Robert playing on
both sides of the board all of you stop
GMS do that
H3 what a tactic that is an amazing
stuff from Maxine and Magnus I think
he's laughing a little bit but he's
chuckling because he's impressed not
because he's happy
and guess what Maxine's gonna win this
game he's gonna have to win it fast and
it's suddenly a four point match I mean
this is not over but Megan did a pretty
good job he's not on the losing side of
being very often but he prolonged it
well into about 19 minutes barely over
19 minutes remaining that's Checkmate
and Maxime down to four he has a chance
that excellent rookie four shot was
unfortunately the high water mark in
bullet for mvl Carlson got back on form
with a win and then a draw and then he
pulled away with three consecutive wins
night on D4 moves Knight D1 picks up the
netany2 with mate
get out of here another little finale to
this match
at this point MBL resigned the match
with the score standing at 17-9 with
eight minutes remaining while it's been
uncommon players are allowed to concede
the match once the bullet clock is under
10 minutes that means that Sunday we
have the match that we have all been
waiting for Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus
Carlson the only two players to have won
a speed Chess Championship and they have
not contested an SCC match since 2017.
don't miss the exciting culmination of
the 2022 speed Chess Championship
foreign
[Music]